[Music]  let's get creative check out this fun  idea trick or treat drew it's time for  halloween at dollar tree grab these  spiders in one book for a total of two  dollars hot glue the spider to the front  of the book oh creepy then mix equal  parts flour and water to make paper  mache mix it really well then we're  going to shred some brown paper oh  thanks for recycling getting all the  nooks and crannies and let it dry oh  it's going to get really really sticky  then we painted the book and the spider  outline with matte black paint  highlighted with gold paint all the way  around oh look how good it looks oh stay  golden dear diary my husband loves  halloween love craft grooms i live for  tip